here is maybe the funniest of all of
these moments Ben Carson Trump's former
Secretary of Hud
uh and former presidential candidate
former neurosurgeon I think
he went so long at CPAC that they
started playing music you know how at
the Oscars you go up and after 30
seconds of thanking people they start
playing music to try to get you off
Ben Carson wouldn't stop talking and
they played music and the music repeated
it was like 30 seconds of Music they
never they didn't think we'll need to go
longer than 30 seconds of music with
anybody but Ben Carson kept talking and
talking and talking
and they just kept playing the music
over and over again and he seemed
completely unaware of what's going on
when they go to Newsmax even the people
on Newsmax seem to feel bad for him
check this out the college students
young staffers what you need to know
about the government so that you don't
have to so that you can hit the ground
running because we need to get these
people he's in the middle of his speech
and they're playing him off because 90
of the of the career employees are
people who live in this area who have
the politics of this area yeah and slow
things down and push things forward
we've got to be able to do much better
than that by understanding this process
so that's what the EBA is all about so
now the crowd is trying to help them by
clapping and sort of like okay let's rap
but he just keeps going
and this will help us to determine and
answer the question
which Benjamin Franklin said if we can
keep it when he starts going into quotes
you know he's not ending It's a
Wonderful system that we have don't let
anybody tell you anything that's
different from that but we're the ones
who are going to have to do it did you
notice the music stopped and now they're
cycling it again they're like we gotta
get him off and he just keeps going and
if you want to know can we keep it find
a World War II veteran and ask him what
was going through their head and D-Day
when they are on the shores of Normandy
and all of those people were being shot
and they stepped over those dead bodies
knowing in many cases they would never
see their loved ones or their Homeland
again
why did they do it
[Music]
oh this guy is unbelievable oh and I
just lost it where did that go oh my
goodness that was crazy
where did that speech go we got to get
it back eventually he walks away that
was crazy the CL the the speech just
went away uh you've got to see the end
because even the Newsmax hosts seem to
be recognizing what's going on here it
is
so that we could live in peace and
safety ask them if we can keep it we can
with all of us thank you so much all
right so there you go
[Applause]
all right Dr Ben Carson
um uh a good speech a good solid speech
one that folks seem to enjoy however it
could it's not lost on myself or Tom
basili who joins us right now who's the
host of America right now
um that they were playing the music I
mean they're behind that's not his fault
yeah no it's not lost on any of us
believe me sir so there is Ben Carson
bringing his electric personality to
CPAC in it going about as well as we
would expect let's now talk about
Kimberly Guilfoyle
every day we see more and more stories
about what tech companies and isps are
doing with your data Facebook just
settled a huge lawsuit alleging they
gave millions of users data to a company
helping the Trump campaign everyone
should be using a VPN every time they
connect to the internet no excuses a VPN
hides your IP address it can keep your
data private from these companies and
even from hackers that's why I reached
out to private internet access about
being our sponsor private internet
access is the only VPN that has proven
in court multiple times they don't log
your browsing history their no log
practices are also independently audited
by Deloitte no other VPN takes your
privacy this seriously lightning fast
for downloads streaming content only
available in other countries works as
well works with all major streaming
platforms with one account you can use
it on up to 10 devices and they have a
30 day money back guarantee and their 24
7 support is amazing go to Pia
vpn.com
Pacman to get 83 percent off that's two
dollars and three cents a month and
you'll get four months free the link is
down below